tutti ragazzi e benvenuto a questo detto
voglio venire come riesco a giocare con
questa roba qui c'è sarà un'impresa
titanica
però lo devo fare per forza perché se no
devo giocare col mignolo e mi esce male
ci provo a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti
questo video sono fa vigente oggi
l'america e quindi siamo tornati su
happy meal
allora prima di iniziare decentemente
costo dito soprattutto alla jazz
macdrive con questo primo che bello
smoking tailleur di michele tipo michael
jackson che si piega in avanti
bellissimo ma ci proviamo ragazzi ci
prova oggi ecco è esattamente ciò grazie
edito grazie la partenza è stata epica
ragazzi non seriamente a patisca è stato
cioè in pene bar zoppo cosa esattamente
successo prima di vincere che non ho
capito un cazzo
ok ok alla parte la partenza è stata
fanno veramente giocare questo cazzo di
the impossibile wheel of kings giorno no
che devo tagliare i capelli la tizia non
ho capito come funziona sta roba è una
roba tipo che io giro e vomito hanno
capito che usa è to speech è ma come
faccio uccidere persone nello
schiacciare il cervello tipo così no
spam
niente come questo faccio ragazzi non
muore nessuno c'è assurdo allora cani o
mica uno ce l'ho fatto il primo almeno
questo ragazzi perché è impossibile o
finalmente ok shin chan parto dai dai
ok migliaio staccato il poverino questo
ok ragazzi come cazzo tiro giù questo
che a testa in giù non è possibile ce la
farò mai nella vita
ok non so come sia possibile ma ho vinto
è merito suo solo merito suo
sicuro è chiuso detto ice cream e mia
inglese che eminem fa le bizze è una
roba tipo rotta della grotta panoramica
diciamo in bici però ragazzi da avessi
davanti le ruote panorami parona mi che
oggi non so parlare manco per il cazzo
come è colpa di uk dai sacri oppure mio
dito che è il mio cervello stava là
dentro e non lo sapevo
ho vinto miyake frontflip pazzesco che
ho fatto
[Musica]
ne andrò yourself da un pezzo che non
facit o yourself mica mi manca anche per
il fatto che non riesco più a lanciarmi
recentemente che lancio brutto era già
schiacciato dalla mia stessa solo un
genio
i primi così non riesco a fare ciò è
assurdo va bè ragazzi veloci a pinto che
non è per me ecco perché non li facciamo
di [ __ ] set c'era un senso c'è una roba
da leggere che non leggerò mai nella mia
vita però va bene è un nuovo modo di
federare ragazzi voi non lo conoscete ma
lo usano lo fanno tutti beh come ce l'ho
fatta a fare una roba normale non perché
diventa leggermente assurdo storia ma
dovevo andare a diventa sempre più
piccola va beh ma ditelo ho perso un
braccio
non chiedetemi come mauro perna iphone
parte 2 iphone apple pubblicità venduti
a che figurerà girare un iphone e ma io
c'ho l'android quindi [ __ ] perché
mi si è incaricata la schiena quindi
rimango così in posizione per tutto il
tempo della partita si può riavviare
questa cazzo di iphone in qualche modo
oppure hanno riavvio livello faccio prix
volevo un iphone nero nero nero mai dato
l'iphone bianco ma eden di calcolo resto
iphone ragazzi e blu nero oppure bianco
oro ma [ __ ] che sono in africa
come ho fatto a perdere le ruote perché
è una scarpa al posto della ruota cazzo
se volevo andare a piedi lo facciano
subito cioè che non è possibile
bye bye casomai cazzo ma perché perdo le
gambe cosa è successo madonna che
frontale ma che dimostrano è questo e
non si capisce niente
ok l'importante che io abbia finito poi
va bene quando jump
oh mio dio sei serio ma io devo saltare
ma non ce la farò mai nella vita a
saltare ok veloci provai così vai così
guarda lì che posizione da yoga che
controllato ed i 6 posto c'è di la
verità è roso dai e dopo lo stretching
facciamo cose serie propri mano queste
se dai no non mi deludere cazzola
possiamo fare ce la possiamo fare mai
così vai così ma è anche una spunta nel
verificato quella di whatsapp ad essere
avanti ragazzi se vi appare la spunta di
whatsapp sappiate che perché ucciso
delle persone non perché qualcuno di
visualizza ai visualizzato testa di
merda e non mi hai risposto ecco infatti
la morale di tutto questo ragazzi che se
visualizzate non rispondete finite di
merda però è un consiglio poi fate
quello che volete ixtreme boltro
facciamo questo che mi sembra figo dead
è una merda ho ripensato vinco subito e
poi cambiamo perché anche posso stare
sempre sui controllo c'è l'altra roba da
far spyphone cosa no
scrivo sono io staccati da è cattiva
star
ecco mi sono staccato dalla convinto ma
cosa che cosa è successo
avevo perso ma non io io io poi opawc so
io poxo trucks so minchia superman ii
che carica da superman che c'è questo
livello sz around me you get the bank si
certo che vuole affatto liuc
[Applauso]
non l'ho capita questa ma va bene
ragazzi cronico ok perché la mia [ __ ]
gambe entrata io no come cazzo
impossibile che le gambe siano ancora
attaccate nonostante io sia
va beh no ma porca merda sono entrato ho
vinto l'importante non è vincere ma
rimanere tutti interi arrivare al
traguardo questo è l'importante
shot gun vengeance allora io ho vinto ma
che cosa cazzo state facendo di pre cosa
che schifo preferivo 50 sfumature di
grigio a questa cosa slanzi quello che
va tirato per infilato nel culo non per
l'anci le testate grazie o lo fai
che cos'è sta roba da poco fa anche
steve ci mancherebbe che steve non
faccia
[Musica]
no no a tutto a posto di melo 6 dei
problemi di immaturi di stronzi vabbè in
the head shot grazie a gianni sono ben
fatto male al dito io di mio ci mancava
soltanto noi minaccia la roba in testa
ma grazie ci taglio la torta duri nostra
non ti hanno uso il culone anche se cosa
che già il successo rea
[Applauso]
ok vabbè ma [ __ ] eva berga
impossibile al piano piano il forcone
della infine nel comma donna stava
morendo
rimango così a saltare fermo fisso
minchia non è possibile ho fatto male di
te si è allungato leggermente il collo
mi dico bye bye bye bye bye bye moderno
stop stavo finendo giù potevo incazzarmi
del germe speak man's world
ma che cazzo è oggi cos'è un mio dio io
lo faccio la veloce giusto per capire il
senso di sto livello troppo è una roba
tipo no no no no no premio no sì che
culo no kat
e vabbè è rimasto il verde ce ne faremo
una ragione
son streetbike con questo mi fa è la
mano amica rossi c'è
g wiz based vai così vai così la yamaha
non era così potremo sicilia ma è la
madonna pio al volo manco nt era così ma
sono ancora vi sono ancora vivo come
com'è possibile
ragazzi vi sembra normale vabbè
maledizione ce la posso fare oh mio dio
che cazzo sono vivo importante che io
sia vivo poi che se c'è una vittoria
grazie mi raccoglie anche un cucchiaino
se possibile per favore enter the box
red
perché a re del tutto rosso tipo babbo
natale faccio babbo natale è la madonna
che grafica in hd manco ferc ride mentre
si ebbe semplice in teoria credo sarà
scritto incisi e perché un casino invece
no invece invece un cazzo invece mi sono
appeso per il cazzo ok ok no sì ho vinto
tanto significi come pensa e allora mi
fai cagherà adosso per niente grazie
vecchio ragazzi prima di concludere
faccio un paio di livelli dedicati a me
che da un pezzo fa vige come iscritto
famiglie ti ammazzo il criceto ma giuro
che durante la notte lo senti urlare
fammi capire fa vj e il massacro vedrai
massacrato forse estivo e tu lo chiami
così mi sembra guarda io massacrerei te
per come lord tiget come mai scritto il
nickname
però lei now lorda a questo livello è
semplice fa vi è andata bene che mi è
scritto favi e non hai messo la j perché
se la mette v maiuscola potevo ucciderti
ho vinto
no cazzo sono quasi da cipro bye bye bye
bye bye dai cazzo che posizione sexy ed
i però l'importante è vincere
vorrei massacro nei passi si tanto vinto
io vai di james pract pensa veloce
veloce sandwich non ho vinto io ho
pensato a quello e non ho vinto perché
no grazie impossibile come faccia sì ho
vinto ho vinto già fatta tema ancora
vittoria perché non c'è solo la vittoria
che se non c'è quello non mi son
contento mi sento un completo tipo
grazie grazie all editing fa vj quiz ita
spero che questo primo mio livello ti
piace se non ti mando che mario nel
letto o fa ridere ridere
giuro che non fa ridere per me può
vincere in realtà si chiama lorenzo
loria loriano loriano c'è una persona
nel mondo che si chiama loriano non
credo ok avanti mi chiamo loriano
sbagliata la nutella
noi veramente preferisco la patata la
nutella attento mio dio che bel quiz che
ho fatto mi chiamo loriano cosa ho
risolto da questa cosa nella mia vita
ragazzi ho paura di fare altri livelli
quindi concluso qui per oggi mi è
bastato spero che vi sia piaciuto
ragazzi spero che mi sia guarito il dito
dopo questa incredibile sessione di
gioco professional
quindi ragazzi se il video mi è piaciuto
ma stato lasciato quanto mi piace anche
a pagina di facebook che come in ogni
video trovate la descrizione se questi
dischi ne tiene i civili devono prossimo
belle ragazze